hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the Greek word Erebos which is coming
from Erin Mia means one who is alone
it's the word that we get hermit from
ultimately because some of the monks who
retreated into the desert later on were
using Greek were were you know the
animals so they are envoy of the desert
and we got that conception from them
Epictetus is talking here about this
very common experience of being in a
state of aramean in a state of forlorn
Ness or we might say loneliness the
question is what does solitude or being
alone really mean so you know like I put
here what is the meaning of being on
one's oh that has a lot to do with how
being on one's own is actually
experienced it can be a good thing in
many respects or it can be a bad thing
many people will do almost just anything
to avoid being alone they'll go out to a
bar so that they don't have to be in
their place by themselves people turn on
the TV for companionship the internet
now has you know a great place to go for
all sorts of ears aughts feelings of
togetherness
this is just as much of an issue in
epictetus this time as it is in our own
modern alienated lonely condition which
actually doesn't have to be that way for
us and I think actually is any worse
than it was in Roman times so the
question is how do we understand being
on one's own and so he's going to draw
this vital distinction between being
forlorn or being lonely and being alone
he says forlorn this means ultimately
being without help or resources the
greek word for this is bois de tous
that it's coming from a verb meaning to
sort of rush to the aid of somebody else
it's used in a lot of combats and and
military discussions but the idea is
that the person who feels like they're
they're sad and lonely because they're
on their own they they feel that way in
part because they can't rely on anybody
else in addition to that there's you
know so maybe some examples here that he
gives and some other qualifications he
says that this often happens when there
is a loss that the person endures of a
relative a close relative like a father
or a brother or a son or a close friend
somebody who one relied upon he actually
says a friend with whom one shared of
that meaning that there was a kind of
intimacy and closeness there losing a
spouse would be a great example and we
can feel this this sense of being on
their own you know all by herself even
if we are with others he gives some some
examples of being in a crowd in Rome he
says if we could be in the city of Rome
which is the largest city in the world
that he knows about with large crowds
meeting us on the streets and so many
other people living in the same house
with us and sometimes even though we
have a multitude of slaves or servants
people can handle all of that stuff all
those people around them and yet feel
like they're totally alone
that they're totally on their own
because they can't rely on any of them
to be there with what they need now from
a stoic perspective what does this mean
they are looking for something from
these other people perhaps reasonably
perhaps unreasonably that that's still a
question that has to be explored in the
particular circumstances you know
they're not getting it so you know this
is something that happens for us all the
time you don't think about contemporary
examples doesn't necessarily just have
to be a spouse it can be any breakup you
know we live in a time where many people
are going to go through what's called
serial monogamy right where they're
going to be in committed relationships
which are probably going to come to an
end they may be in a whole sequence or
series of these before they wind up with
the person who they're going to spend
the most time with or at least the last
of the time that they have available and
each time that that happens you know
when there's a breakup we'll get it this
way either you're breaking up with them
or they're breaking up with you
sometimes people will actually break up
with another person preemptively just to
make sure they're not the one who gets
dumped right and why don't they want to
be the one who gets dumped because then
you feel for a warm you feel like man
I'm never gonna find that person things
are never going to work out that way
nobody will ever love me again same
thing can happen by the way when one
loses one's job coworkers can become one
support network and that can be taken
away from you at any moment and then
suddenly you're left without moorings
you're like what do I do
I mean I can go look for jobs if there
are any but now what do I do with the
other time of the day so people get on
the internet and then they get into
those communities and then maybe that
you know falls apart as well there's all
sorts of possibilities in our modern age
for exactly the same sort of experience
that epictetus is talking about he also
talks about more intensive
a sense of this when one is encountering
hostility so when one is exposed to
those who had injured one so think about
a child who is being isolated and
bullied they are going to feel for more
nobody is coming to their their aid
perhaps not even the authorities who
should be intervening it's a very lonely
place to be isn't it and you know we
could think similarly about the the
student who begins you know taking
classes in their 40s and has been out of
school for a long time they're doing
sort of you know job retraining and they
they take some online classes they don't
know anybody they're not quite sure
about what they want to be doing it
seems difficult to make friends in that
sort of circumstance and now they're
having all this material thrown at them
that may feel very lonely as well and so
you can talk about lots of situations in
which people are feeling this this
feeling now the question that epictetus
wants to ask us is is it possible to be
alone without being forlorn or lonely
and the answer is yes but the answer is
yes for some people it's not actually
possible for everybody to be alone
without a feeling lonely some people are
against the state that they can't be by
themselves and now the question is well
why not that's the interesting part from
the stoic perspective he does know that
we do in fact have a sort of natural
affinity or a connection where there's
Koinonia could be sharing with other
people this is something that the Stoics
believe is part of human nature it's
built into our very fabric of our
existence and so we have a natural
tendency to want to socialize at least
to some at some degree you know on some
things but it is also possible to be
self-sufficient to be able to
communicate not just with other people
but with ourselves
now you can only really be up for that
if in fact you like yourself otherwise
you're stuck with a jerk or somebody who
you're terrified of or somebody who
keeps on making stupid decisions that
you regret and deplore and then you
don't want to be with somebody like that
right so in order to be able to be the
kind of person who can in fact be in on
their own and be okay with it Epictetus
the stoic would say you need to do some
self development you need to cultivate
yourself so that you become a good
person the kind of person who actually
wants to be with this person that you
are so and uses the example of Zeus Zeus
is is the the Greek god who is sort of
the stand-in for God you know the
capital G for for the Stoics and the
Stoics if you read this section the
stomach's he's referencing a world
conflagration Stoics believed that the
universe would every so often you know
just be destroyed in flames and then be
you know become again and Zeus would be
there in the the world conflagration he
would be there on his own and he says
okay so let's think about this if being
alone is enough to make one for a lord
you will have to say that even Zeus
himself is forlorn at the world
conflagration and but wails himself
wretched me I am neither here in North
inan or Apollo nor a word brother and
her son or grandson or kinsman he says
some people actually do think that Zeus
is saying that because they can't
imagine being on their own or anybody
else being on their own and being okay
with it and actually enjoying it what is
this he says you know Zeus communes with
himself is at peace with himself
contemplates the character of his
governance and occupies himself that it
is appropriate to himself he can be on
his own many other people can so we want
to be able to be on our own in part be
we may have to be on our own a lot you
know think about places where that's
going to be the case riding the bus
going to the airport you know sitting in
your apartment doing your homework by
yourself all these sorts of things going
to certain kinds of work where you have
to be the on your own of course you're
on your own with work but you're still
on your own do you need do you have a
sort of insatiable pathological need to
automatically bring in connections to
anybody whatsoever or can you do you
have the freedom to actually be on your
own and then connect with people when
you choose to that's the the key
question here he also says that we are
part of the divine governance the DUI
the Oasis DUI cases which is sort of
like a giant household so we're not
truly on our own at any given time
because even when we think that we're on
our own
there is also the divine which we are in
some way connected with so we're not
truly on our own
totally abandoned but the person who
doesn't see that would feel totally on
their own if they they don't have you
know others and they haven't made
friends with themselves there's one last
thing that that epictetus says here
which i find particularly striking and
interesting in this he talks about the
seats the peace of Caesar right the
Imperial Roman peace he says behold now
Caesar seems to provide us with profound
peace there's no longer any Wars nor
battles and our bringing it in John
larger scale or piracy but in any other
word we may travel by land or sail from
the rising of the Sun to its setting can
he then here's the question can he
Caesar the political authority the
bureaucracy that he put in place can he
provide us with freedom from the other
things that assails can he provide us
with peace from fever from shipwreck
from fire earthquake and lightning can
he give us peace from love from sorrow
from envy he cannot from absolutely none
of these things but the doctrine of the
philosophers promises to give us that
peace from these troubles too so he says
when a man has this kind of peace
proclaimed him
who is it proclaimed by not by Caesar by
God through reason through our Faculty
of reason this is something well worth
keeping in mind those who are caught in
crisis situations in you know situations
where society is broken down of course
are not in a situation like what the
cattiness is talking about with the
Peace of Caesar those of us living
fortunate enough to be living in you
know the first world you know unless
we're in in particularly bad areas of it
are living in a situation very much like
the the peace of Caesar but all of that
prosperity all of this massive
connection that's possible for us we're
allowing me to talk to you through the
internet for example and you to draw
this up anytime that you want none of
that's actually going to make us feel
less lonely if we haven't actually
learned how to deal with being alone
being on our own if we haven't made as I
was saying before friends with ourselves
remember - I have another video just on
friendship that epictetus thinks you
can't really be friends with somebody in
a lasting way unless you are a good
person unless you've engaged in some
moral cultivation and development and
are you know a road at least to virtue
if not already virtuous in part because
you're not going to remain constant
things are going to come in between it's
the same relation with one's self if
there are conflicts that haven't really
been worked through Graham's not even
identified with in person it's going to
be quite difficult for them
to be on their own so that applies just
as much in our time as it does in epic
foetus is time and the peace of the
Roman Empire